speaking about you spelling uh circada
incorrectly yeah circada i realized like
the other day i'm like [ __ ] i can't
spell [ __ ] without autocorrect anymore
my spelling is so bad without
autocorrect yeah that's pretty much
something i realize now when it's not on
i just kind of like type [ __ ] and i know
that it will fix it for me
i just type fast
yeah
yeah i mean i i'm i got something
similar as well where i'm like i can't
do mental arithmetic anymore like i i
literally like what like i'm just like
oh what's uh nine times eight and i'm
just like
get out the calculator
like i'm so reliant i should do it but
it'll take me 20 seconds i can do it but
it requires thinking and i don't i i'm
not all about that man nine times no
that's easy though what's going to say
think about it girl how long is it
no wait are you
72. there you go you go okay
i had to think about it
graduating masters in engineering by the
way
what was your method of getting that
i
don't
because the nine times table is the
easiest yeah that's what i would i would
the nine times nine is 81 then just
minus eight
that's that's way too complicated even
it isn't even easier i should have done
that anything times nine is super
[ __ ] easy i should have done that i
don't know no i mean i don't really have
a system it's just figuring whatever
your brain is wired to do fast right
yeah well for me if it's nine times
eight then it's like well eight is so it
starts with a seven because whatever
you're timesing by nine is always one
digit below yeah and then the two digits
uh sums up to nine am i i never was
always nine you know how every time you
would ever have like a new math teacher
they would always teach you that weird
way of solving a plus and a minus yeah
yeah i mean and they were like right so
we're gonna add 425 to uh 522 and then
they're going to do right so we're going
to add the four to the five easy it's
great that you know i'm like
do we really need to write this down can
we just like can we just
and then there's always like the like
just a really obscure ways to do it as
well where it's like there's gonna be an
easier way yeah yeah
all right so when you bring the one over
pull out your dictionary yeah or it
would be like dividing by and they would
have this weird ass timetable or
something to do it and i'm like this
feels so convoluted why don't why not
just like figure out some other methods
like teacher when am i ever going to
divide 973 by 67 like i'm never going to
i'm never going to go and count down i
don't need to know this [ __ ] every every
single like yeah like it is great that
you if you can do that with your with
your mind but there's a party trick
there there's absolutely no setting
where you are ever not going to be using
a calculator and even if you are they
will not allow you to do that because
they won't trust you you should be using
a calculator for good practice you know
even if you could divide yeah insane
numbers that people like nah that's not
it it's good for like estimates when
you're talking engineering terms you're
like okay well maybe you try this much
no i don't think that just just off the
top of my head that doesn't seem right
yeah yeah yeah that's good but in
general like you know those exams you
know it's just funny how like mental
arithmetic has just become become kind
of like a party trick yeah like you
there's there's always like you always
see that one guy every so often where
you get the you get like the bill and
they can just like divide exactly
the right amount in their head yeah but
but it's also like the shittiest type of
party trick because it's the party trick
that you do and nobody believes
and people check it anywhere either way
it's like nah let me put the calculator
out
oh it is right wow very good
times five is 25. i remember
[ __ ] let me check that yeah
yeah
i just work via round numbers now that
is just my life but yes exactly the same
spelling now where i just i could not
live without autocorrect and i i don't
know i feel like
it's it's do you have those words that
you just you you know what they look
like but you're like i just can't bother
to learn how to spell it right you know
what i mean i just want necessary i was
literally about to say that
that is the one where i'm like i
honestly cannot remember which is the
two c's 2s yeah i just typed two s's
right
i don't know i just don't know i'm
pretty sure the one for me that always
[ __ ] me up that i still never get right
is guaranteed yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i
was like is the u in there is there an a
in this
is it
or is it guaranteed
this is what i just i don't care i
haven't like yeah
necessarily i'm just like i'm pretty
sure it's two s's
no it's not is it it's two s's i don't
know maybe it is
yeah
n-e-c-e-s-s-a-r-y right yeah i'm pretty
sure it is but yeah hold on let me check
i'll never get out of the autocar right
i just type and then click yeah it's
that one yeah yeah
but the thing about spelling is that it
doesn't
at the end of the day spelling is
irrelevant
at the end of the day you know you can
spell word wrong and people will still
get like the meaning of the word most of
the time right
isn't there this phonetics yeah i mean
haven't you seen like the video where if
you put the first letter right and the
last let's write it just mix it up
on the internet i've seen that yeah yeah
it's the thing you assume the ballerina
that spins the other way too gone
have you seen the dress that's blue and
grey gold oh yeah
i remember that oh my god i completely
forgot about that the internet was on
fire for a week unnecessarily over a
[ __ ] dress i remember meme culture
but i remember that was like the hot
thing back then back in the day
um
people i i knew i knew that dress meme
went too far when people like all right
so i went into photoshop and i got the
color drop
and i can confirm the hex digits that it
is in fact blue and gold